[Music]
i don't
tell a girl to shut up because that's
rude i just go
that's interesting yeah because i
feel like i started
i feel like i started if you hit the
table again
i will fight you what happens you're
redoing everything here get a new table
i know we're do the people know what's
happening outside i have an l-shaped
table with
uh rollers on the bottom that lock yeah
so people can come in and out because
stress out when people that uh are not
anorexic like me
come in and can't fit right okay we can
move it move the cameras
um high wit i did
when i took too much nyquil
uh and went out and peed in the yard
in a full blazer okay full work blazer
workplace uh after uh performing at the
comedy store full pollop
blazer uh predator pink
predator paula powell yeah she was a
predator of
pussy i think she was she she uh took
the pussy oh really 100
yeah i don't i don't know enough about
her pound stone that's an unfortunate
last name
yeah i mean cummings i i think i win
that one you might
i might i might i love playing old songs
we haven't heard her wasn't she accused
of something paula pounced on was she
i thought she was no with those shoulder
pads how would you manage to even
like how do you rape someone with those
shoulder pads it's a hard
i guess you could she was right you
could what was it mark
all of your friends not a family member
all of your friends
these are i don't know have never met
her how old do you think i
am bitch how old do you think
i am i think i'm older than you i'm 38.
i mean i'm let's be honest i've been 66
for 20 years
yeah peptides
um i like playing old songs yeah and
seeing what it does to people okay and
seeing what emotions come up
okay this is like my shit okay um
i love it i love it but were you a 90s
you were 90s new york
i'm 37 18
what were you listening to
who knows more the lyrics mario let's
see okay
okay okay let's see we're going to see
it's going to be tricky
let's see who's going to win this one
cut we're done yeah why you got like
counting crows
i hooked up with adam derrick no he was
18. did he have fake hair that was his
real hair
they were fake he asked me to come um uh
sit with him while he put in the plugs
get out of here i was 18.
i was of legal age i was an intern at
e-entertainment
okay uh i was a fucking huckster
hustler before huckster hustler shit
right what's happening so wait you were
what do you mean by that like you were
trying i was an
intern move your career forward by
hooking up oh wait i was
i've talked about this on the podcast
and the fact let's talk about it again
and if you guys kiss
did you yeah
were you on that dick like bop bop
no always the bottom eternally a bottom
really
i don't i always feel like i'm going to
break a guy's dick
really remember when you told me guys
want you to start on top
yeah yes always on the bottom always
yeah just lay there
and pretend you're crying you've got top
hair
that's not bottom hair no this is top
that's top hair but i'm a bottom
incredibly traditional and submissive in
my
irl but you also will do some
some butt stuff sure you're a butt
stuffed girl well you're
remember what i call stuff remember when
i called you yeah you called me and i
remember talking i went hey so guys just
go straight for the butt
and you told me in the shower you did
butt stuff
yeah no lube psalms lube yeah you dream
dude in the shower
yeah for me the weirdest thing for me is
when i'm dating someone and it's a guy's
first time doing
doing butt stuff is that what they say
twice now yeah
it's my first time too i'm like bitch am
i taking your virginity
like this makes me this is so
monster this is so i feel like a
pedophile you pull up
i'm like i have to pretend i've never
i've never done this before
like bitch a lot of guys are not into it
i'm not into it at all interesting oh um
shit is there it's a lot of shit shit
that comes out have you seen the yellow
girls
no video can you pull up yolo girls yeah
um uh i don't we don't have a young why
would anybody like it do you like it
i like the mentally do you like it but
not physically nobody physically likes
that that's not how we're designed
physically you don't like it nobody
physically want me to answer
go at some point i thought we were gonna
have a rapport i am so obsessed with you
okay cool a rap report
um i have you had him on here yes
he's funny he's annoying sometimes but
he's funny i love
him no he's funny he's fucking he's an
uncle yes he's our uncle yes he's our
annoying
fucking uncle yeah and he
if you only know him on instagram he is
annoying he's like hanging out with him
in person you're like oh
i know this is funny here's why you love
him in the beginning
yeah i was like headphones he's like i
can hear you yeah i'd love it
that's why he was like i can hear you
you're right there yeah yeah that's the
whole thing yeah yeah he goes yeah
he's like take your fucking headphones
off i can hear you speaking we're in an
uber and uh
i don't know what he did i think we're
in uber who are telling me about an uber
ride i forget this is in like montreal
and um again i get an uber
guy doesn't even take the passenger seat
and put it up
i go what is this are we expecting
somebody
like who's offset the poor guy driving
they didn't just slide the seat up six
inches he's such a beast
well he actually when he came on the
podcast last year he was like
oh no when he was on um charlemagne show
he was like
lauren hill has not made a hit in 20
years yeah
yeah she doesn't i went and saw lauren
hill uh
at the club nokia which i did with rogan
and jim jeffries for an australia
fire remember when we cared about
australia's
fires do you want me to be honest or not
uh please
i mean don't wh what kind of bitch-ass
rhetorical question is that i'm just
saying do you want me to be on do you
want me to go with you if you
don't know me by now i'm just saying did
you really care about the fires
yes i remember when you were trying to
say that giraffe you know that i was in
a fight you were trying to say i was
getting tired as a kid you were trying
to save a draft
yes and that shit made me laugh for
about a week
there's a video and i hope it's still up
you're like go in there like after the
fires have went through the animal farm
it's in it what is it called a farm
petting zoo a ranch whatever it is and
you're like oh what's the name of the
draft
cherokee family stanley stanley yeah
yeah yeah stanley was here as you can
see
the wood is burnt the the fires have
ravaged this area you're like bringing
up like pieces of the ground you're like
definitely fire i have a folder oh do
you want to see my folder
i have a folder what do you do
what would you do where would you go
with it do you know where would you go
you're right by the way still working on
it by the way it's been six months it's
a day
he's dead they switched him out it's
been two years they switched no there's
another one named jackson silmar that
they're trying to get he's dead too
uh no yes they're they're in a box in
sylmar they're in a box under the ground
they're dead i have tabs on them oh that
one's
i have look i have look at this folder
yeah i'm tracking
animal abusers this is my kink this is
what i
do yeah i am like the sherlock holmes
would you do anything this is going to
be a little bit gross
would you ever have a romantic
relationship with an animal
i mean that like have you ever like
loved the animals so much you just
wanted them to no
pleasure no because yes i do you have
yeah go say it because what you're doing
it is you're saying it
i do scratch my dogs labia
dicks sticks yeah yeah and i'm not a
lesbo
i'm not a lesbo lesbos
i haven't heard that word it's like
porno i mean you heard that word when
you got your hair
uh look what's the worst word lesbo
what's the worst word
that exists yeah i mean i think we all
know i'm like okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's the one
there's one that's the only is there any
word that's worse
that's worse than that yeah my friend
dove used the k word for jewish people
when he got cut off uh-huh he got cut
off not circumcised
uh yeah are you circumcised when you
have a kid or you
when you have a kid you're going to
circumcise them uh
i don't know there's a lot a boy or girl
depends
girl i definitely won't like there's
that's good
circumstances yeah yeah well we'll not
at all like we're not going to circle
we're not going to do anything i'll let
the hymen be intact the hymen's intact i
don't think you circumcise that you slap
that table
one more thing is it because they can
hear it i have misophonia
misophonia which me oh you don't know
something oh i know something you don't
you know everything i don't know um
which is that
uh i hear things because i grew up in
alcoholic home you guys know this
yeah um i can and women there's not one
woman in this room
this is this is my favorite shit just
like a bunch of men staring at me
underestimating me let's
fucking go we're underestimating you
we're in a fucking estate okay
that none of us live in nobody's
underestimating you right now you're
clearly renovating you've got signs of
the occult all over this place
signs of the occult because i did the
craft but we didn't know that so mark is
out there videotaping these like six six
sixes in a circle going like what's
going on
when my dog uh sliced his hand open a
paw open
and there was blood everywhere and there
was like pentagrams everywhere
and the workers were you're sacrificing
animals
you're sacrificing i would never that's
why you want a giraffe that's how you
stay young forever
if you could sacrifice a giraffe you
stay young serena chrome
all day bitch all day why do we get
along so well
i don't know you're just fun it's weird
yeah why is it weird why are you
you hate acting and you're such a good
actor ugh i hate it
doug doesn't think i'm a good actor
you're wrong can i tell you but you're
the best director
i've said this to you before i know
you're the best director and
it's almost to the point like if anybody
asked me to do the movie if i if it was
really short and i really liked it maybe
if it was a full movie
and you were directing it i would do it
but most other people know
i mean that sincerely i'm not blowing i
just don't care enough it's boring
i agree with you it's literally it feels
like
here's the line that i think is really
funny do me a favor say that line
if you think of something else it's
funny try it we should have got blake
here
yeah because that was the scene but like
you were just letting me do
other things you're like okay yeah we'll
figure it out in the edit yeah it was
just great
yeah like i don't well comedians we are
all about
what's the best it just has to be the
best yeah we don't
there's no egos there's no we don't
stick to shit yeah we're
we're we heckle ourselves bitch i'm
saying
like we just want the best thing all the
time yeah
um but you're the best you're the best
director i'm not just saying that
because you know i criticize you a lot
well you know that um
the next thing i want to do what's that
my plan is i want to be walt disney
yeah you could do it you could do it i
want to create experiences
you could do it you created a fucking
jeffrey epstein's mansion
[Music]
numerous times the snacks were delicious
did you ever get asked to be involved in
anything i had never
heard of him until tim dillon
timmy's shout out to tim i know there
was like an andre bella's connection i
knew andre
a lot he's a hotelier in new york city
oh new york
really new york i don't know about hotel
the standard i live there i'm sorry i
don't understand the standard
i love that whatever what's your
ancestry ancestry um
like what do you mean by that like where
are you from from uh scotland
really yeah my mom was born and raised
in scotland have you okay
uh scotch irish no scott dish
yeah just the scottish part have you not
done your ancestry no i don't want to do
that
you should no cause what if what if i
find out my mom was just like
uh whoever you know what i mean and then
or what's up
raped because when i find out my dad's
not my real dad my dad's my hero
i don't want to know your dad's my hero
he's a pretty good guy
the fact that he was a news yeah anchor
yeah that's a plot twist yeah and like
the coolest stories
did the first ever story about hip-hop
music wow
yeah for nbc produced it and then
so you inherited here's the thing you
inherited all these good amazing things
curiosity from him for sure curiosity
yeah pacing
um uh hip-hop
all of it right right yeah uh uh
investigative journalism yeah he's super
curious but yeah
you also inherited negative shit yeah
what's that
um from your grandparents grandparents
nothing negative about
scottish perfect actualized human being
why didn't you um let me know tons of
tons of everything i think that like
yeah i think the curiosity comes from my
dad and then just the drive comes from
my mom my mom's like insane her drive is
unbelievable
she's relentless she will destroy
anything in her path yeah i mean that
100 percent
love her like right now if she was
what's her name sandra sandra you can't
fuck with a sandra no sandy d
wow that's not really her name and
where's she from uh
she's from scotland scotland yeah people
from scotland
highlanders yeah these motherfuckers had
to ward
off bears with their energy
there's no bears in scotland at all it's
more i was trying to think of
what the predator was the english
what yeah what were the english what
have you seen braveheart
the english uh yeah i've seen bravery
gibson come on the pod
i have some questions about your
voicemails
have you heard those voicemails recently
dude he's a wild boy
i re-listen he's a wild 17 movies in
production
he can come back he's back that's
greatness no what a greatness he's back
he's greatness he played will farrell's
dad in the
movie he's in mark wahlberg he's in the
santa movie he's santa yeah he played
santa yeah
yeah this motherfucker those voicemails
who hates the jews more than santa i
gave up my
lakers tickets
the the anger the rage in his heart
yeah dove do you forgive him dubs jewish
let's forgive people
really let's do it okay who do we
forgive who don't we forgive
but also i want to plan your wedding and
uh fight me
about uh why you didn't take my advice
on your engagement
because you had i would have done it
better you had an
incredible but also creepy
way of proposing can you i want you to
say it
okay i forgot you didn't forget because
you put thought into this you clearly
put thought into this
it was you this is the crux of it to
propose
in the conscious state and the
subconscious state oh that's right
the closest you don't need this yeah go
go go go go go you you told me this
as a real person you really thought this
was the right way to do yes i wanted you
to make my girlfriend pass out she was
your girlfriend at the time
yeah while she was sleeping yeah put the
engagement ring on her finger
yeah and then when she woke up she
wouldn't have a choice
you wanted me to take away her power of
choice i think that is
her body your choice
isn't that what's wrong with the world
uh i i
your body your body andrew's choice
always
yeah um i wanted the
that to me is the hottest shit ever
cancel me i don't give a fuck
yeah um waking up because you don't know
and that oh and when you video her yes
put up
yeah yeah yeah i mean this is terrifying
right this is absolutely terrifying
uh hot content i would have gone viral
yeah yeah um to put cameras up
i wanted you to put cameras up
put an engagement ring on her finger
while she was sleeping
and figure she was going to get up she
was going to brush her teeth wash her
face and be like
that would have been amazing but what if
she said no then it would have was she
gonna say no no
she wasn't gonna say no not with that
rock
your boy went in she wouldn't say no to
you what is she netflix
even they didn't yeah they always say
yes eventually
no means yeah no means yes in
entertainment yeah
in entertainment yes i don't know
have you ever been in that situation uh
see it again a different way
have you ever been in the situation
where like you know a network or
somebody said no to you
and then they came around and they
realized that the right thing to do is
just say yes
no i got canceled a lot or yeah
i got canceled a lot and then i would
like see
a network head be like we were wrong
this this this or this was ahead of its
time like i did a show at hbo
that uh pilot that you auditioned for
to play my boyfriend yeah and you were
you we were ageist
this is how you were ageist to me you
were the best person for the job yeah he
came in
crushed it yeah but i thought he looked
too young
right to play my boyfriend yeah which is
prejudice and i hired brett goldstein
who's now on um handy pam
what's the thing on apple with jason
sudeikis i don't know
i don't know um i don't know
cut it out apple uh you know it was
we're not watching anything on apple i
was
cut it out do you have anything in
production with them but cut it the fuck
out you see the stupid apple with a bite
out of it i'm not watching a tv show
like that
do you have something in production with
them
do you i have bunga bunga the story of
silvio
berlusconi you are very similar the
italian
prime minister trump he's but he was a
bad motherfucker he was
trump before trump trump got his
playbook from silvio berlusconi
interesting
bought all the airwaves what you want to
say
said say it twenty years double it say
it into the mic
once we get the truffle started we call
him the truffle pig the truffle pig yeah
he's the truffle pig
but you can talk into it um
uh he bought all the airwaves controlled
all the airwaves w
used to make tv shows and films in italy
for this italian company uh until i
stole him
that's what you do yeah oh shit so he
knows a lot about this oh you know
silvio
indiana productions is the name of the i
hosted bunga bunga
the podcast for wondering oh wow you
haven't listened to it
do you not know who i am yo he's not
underestimating
girls on every floor dove yeah
he came to the middle of nowhere i don't
know where we are
you said that last time i still don't
know we're near rogan's old studio
okay we're at my home you're my family
deal with that thank you yeah what's up
thank you so the engagement we'll get
back to sylvia berlusconi a second apple
yeah i mean look there's gonna be a
point where people just go
google to watch a show and we don't the
networks don't exist it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
yeah so whoever's financing it it
doesn't
you know acura is owned by jaguar
right which is owned by no one cares
yeah this is this is how i get deals
done i just trash the network so just
let me do my thing no i know that i got
two years no i get it i'll have an apple
um you're the uh you're using the game
yes
shout out to neil strauss shout out to
you have you spoken to him
no oh dude that guy is the economic
hitman of pussy
i'm good like imagine making millions of
dollars teaching guys how to just like
fuck girls like their objects and then
selling a book about how to have a
meaningful relationship right after
it's genius yeah create the addiction
and then solve it yeah yeah
yeah yeah create scientology
rogan and i spoke about it i know i'm
aware but i was right or wrong
uh you need that uh you need to clear up
clear it up clear is there a case no no
clear it up no you know what i i i fuck
with it i fuck with the nexium cult
really the next team cult makes a lot of
sense i'm having sarah edmondson from
the
by the way i'm on season two with val
bitch
and it had her on my ig live coming on
the podcast but this fucking quarantine
shit
do you have any notes on my podcast by
the way because i i
no these are my notes for you oh okay
god um
you don't know who keith renery is i i
know about the niceium or nexium or
whatever it is
because you're a cult leader so yeah you
should know about
them all all about it you could have a
good cult what's wrong with you study
them all
yeah that's him he's not that bad no
he's
cute but he's short and bow-legged
that's the problem yeah yeah
and a malignant narcissist yeah the
narcissist you know what i mean
he's like in his body all really
like the despots mostly were short
napoleon
uh uh what does despite mean despot like
uh the
um didactic leaders that were
oppressive just real quick in the future
when i ask you what a word means
don't use a bigger word to describe it
please don't don't don't do that ever
again
stop pretending how about
do me a favor stop pretending you're
dumber than you are
because you want to be new york why is
new york dumb by the way
you know that this is boxing okay go
don't you think are we boxing
don't you think that this is what we do
on the podcast now yes
yeah should we start calling out people
like to come on our podcast to box with
us
yeah but not debating that's a little
annoying it's like ben shapiro
podcast don't get me started i'm i know
i know i'm gonna do starters but you
know what i'm saying but you know what
i'm saying
i no i haven't okay he retweets me
sometimes so now i'm all right
but like do you know what i mean like
schumer come on my podcast yeah yeah
like that kind of thing
yeah that's kind of what we're doing
with podcast now right no i mean like
come fight with me no i don't want to
fight with people but i want to just
have a great time but we're sparring but
we're not fighting
sparring we're at busting balls busting
balls yeah busting balls that's good
these are synonyms yeah but it's not
okay
you're the guy that's like okay that we
said this last time
i didn't say you were a bitch i said you
were being a bitch you're like
trying to get me on a technicality yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but that's actually i like that lucky
lady yeah lucky lady lucky lady your
lady's very lucky
she's lucky so i thought lucky girl went
i thought yeah
she is fucking weird she's lucky she's a
beautiful girl
and shit lucky girl body won't stop
body won't stop and the ring is stupid
yeah the ring is stupid yeah your boy
went in
the i don't know about the buzzer though
talk more about it
when the ring looks like that when it's
fucking when it's a rink
when she gets the ring i think you
should have pranked her but whatever
pranked her
okay she's been dreaming about this day
for probably the majority why do you
think why do you think women just dream
about
being proposed to all the time they
don't we dream about threesomes all the
time why can't you dream about being
proposed to
all men dream about threesomes all the
time yeah
that's true there's one two three five
men in this room raise your hand if you
dream about threesomes
all the time yeah one person raised
their hand not every single second a day
but throughout the day
you might see something in the time of
coved yeah
for sure threesomes why why is not it
was one
a pussy and a butthole not enough you
want two pussies and two i don't want
a butthole okay so you want two pussies
why
are four tits and two pussies yeah why
it's more than two and do they have to
be a certain
like what if they're two flat-chested
women
great tits
why not like what what's the threesome
what's the logic
what's the math it's just more i think
it's gluttony at the end of the day
you know it's just more you know why do
you have a double chocolate chip more
people to apologize to the next day want
more people to disappoint
more people they might have stds too
more utis
i don't believe in them you don't
believe in sdi
stis stds i don't believe in stis
what's an sti doesn't exist
i don't have to believe in it
how about that that's nice see him
you're like on some alan greenspan shit
where you talk in a way that it's
impossible
the fed guy mm-hmm it's impossible to
argue with you because you
aren't making sense but it sounds so
smart yeah
do you know about the fed uh it's all
fake i know
i love it i love it i got no worm holder
did i get any jokes in your new special
yes i pitched a couple bangers you had a
no you know you had a banger you had a
few bangers
oh you did do we can we say
yeah because these might be your friends
these might be your friends we can say
it and then we can
put it in the stanley tucci the stanley
tucci joke about uh
you don't believe in stereotypes he goes
you play the sassy gay sidekick in every
movie
stereotypes paid for your house in the
hills where you avoid black people
you weren't there this is back when we
were doing the youtube and it was so
good that we kept it for the netflix
but it was remember the all the celebs
do that stupid black and white videos
yeah
and literally we're like oh yeah because
we need something for and i didn't know
tucci none of us knew these people yeah
yeah yeah right and i called you
and you were like in the middle of doing
whatever the fuck you're doing yeah and
like
you know things are like pat like
banging in the background there's like
pots and shit you're like moving around
crying and
maybe crying and then you just start
doing these like really like harsh roast
jokes about these people and like at
first we're laughing and at the end
we're like
i don't think whitney likes these people
at all
i think there might be a person but it
was tucci
it's like all the jokes i'm not allowed
to say exactly i'm
at the i'm a roast bitch like
you're really you're amazing that's my
thing yeah that's my thing
yeah yeah people don't know that but you
came in and you you
helped us you were there for like two
days two days
i came in for one full day and then you
took me out the next day because
everyone needed to rest or had covet or
something yes but we didn't go in the
next day
yeah um but you came for a day and then
you really helped us and i thought it
was so sweet and i threw your your shoes
out the window
i loved your that's right i loved your
he doesn't like a wedge he'll hate it
men don't like a wedge shield is this
excellent explain what we're talking
about we're talking about the sneaker i
was wearing
i was wearing a sneaker hill cute
sneaker heel
i'm a 90s bitch for life but that never
exists in the 90s
nobody does this sneaker hill thing it
is absolutely disgusting
and i mean this with all love okay
ladies
it looks horrible ladies yeah because
there are women
what do you want me to call them ladies
isn't what you want to be called
it's just zim zim is that it no i'm just
i'm just saying
they them her hair she she has was
whatever
oh dude we have her in the special oh
yeah yeah that's really funny
there's like a line i forget what is
there it's like see the thing is that
white males and the picture that pops up
is elliot do you know her
uh him whatever with this
i'm not allowed to make one mistake like
i'm joking no oh we're going to forgive
people
hold on we're going to go through who we
should and shouldn't forgive
him are you she whatever i do not no he
is
elliot he is brilliant brilliant because
he got all the money
at every stage of the career like when
he was straight right yeah
when he was a girl yeah he got the money
but now he's the oppressor he's a
patriarchy wait for it
then he got the gay money from vice he
had a show about like traveling around
as like a gay person around the world
mm-hmm it was literally there was a gay
in the title
right and then flips the switch
to to trans guy right and now
is gonna get the trans role i mean it's
a genius but
can never brilliant connect cannot i was
asking ben about this i was like
you still can eliot not play a gay man
can elliott not
play a gay man why what is she into
she's into chick still
straight man she's a straight man dates
women dates women
yes exactly can't play a gay man can't
play a gay man but can she play a woman
like she's playing on umbrella academy
or is that stealing a job is that
stealing a job
who gives a fuck i've been saying that
for the greater part of my career
literally who gives a
fuck i do not people are
have three jobs and they just want to go
see a fucking movie
they want to be entertained they want to
laugh they just left target
the fucking overdraft fee i'm on the
phone with the god
damn cable guy who won't show up and i
just want to be entertained i don't give
a fuck who's playing it
make me laugh make me feel something you
know what entertainers
we're your babysitters my kids are on
the fucking couch
i need to go run some goddamn errands
yeah i need to go into the fucking shed
and get the fucking oil to put in the
car because i
fix my own car and i
i'm my own handyman of my home i'm
fixing the screen door and i need my
kids to look at a fucking
thing yeah i don't give a fuck i think
they assume
i think everyone assumes we're all
fucking pervy predator freaks
no no no no no they don't care no no no
no
not us i mean i mean hollywood they're
like
yeah we know you're all perverts we
don't care do you think everyone's a
pervert in hollywood
that's i don't like generalizations like
that i don't right can you just
make a generalization you know what i
mean no i don't
everyone hollywood's a perfect i think
everyone is a pervert
and we all are have to sort of clamp it
down okay you think everyone's a pervert
i mean and everybody has to clamp it
down i think based
i think i think sex started what does
that mean everyone's a pervert sex
started being
consensual like you think mark is a
pervert mark
what is pervert define pervert let's
agree on the definition of pervert mark
co-wrote the show with me the netflix
show
right um he co-created the show can i
say something can i say one more thing
he he has been with one woman his whole
life and he is married
is he a pervert that's pretty sick
sick in a cool way or what because i
can't tell with you no straight man
would ever love a woman that much whoa
shots fired grabbed a mine that's like
that's like that is completely true
that's like me and benton what is is
mark the new benton
navy yeah your kink is like the same
pussy every time
yes
like no one's ever fucked this pussy
before yeah like the same one
it's the best it's like it's like
wearing sandals that are only yours that
you wear for years
your feet fit perfectly into you
comparing your wife's vagina to sandal
flip-flops
like birkenstocks or rainbows not like
shit not like
i have a great what's her name alicia
alicia i have a divorce
attorney
i'm just saying not everybody's a
pervert my crew is pretty responsible
everybody's got girlfriends with
fianceed up wife though
we are dove dove will only be with
jewish women
oh interesting only be with jewish women
do you have to because your family
eventually but i haven't up until this
point that's why he's not married but
he'll only marry and have a family with
jewish women he will not be with someone
who's not jewish i'm into that that's
fine
whatever i'm only into guys that you
know they're what
don't challenge me they don't
so what's the difference i'm just saying
don't you think that he should maybe
expand his search a bit i think you
should stay in your lane and let him do
whatever the fuck he needs to do for him
what is that what is what is this what
this is my friend right here
it's my business this is my business is
it i've known this kid since i'm 18
years old
okay yeah you talk like me i say that
since i'm 18. is that new york that's
east coast
yeah you're trash from florida no i'm
trash from virginia in west virginia oh
sick
appalachian motherfucker which is scotch
irish
are you scotch iron yes i'm scotch irish
west virginia coal mining do people
know that that's why i can direct movies
and do all this shit at one time because
these women were in
hollows in mountains barefooted
fighting getting raped and fighting off
motherfuckers like with their
just crazy yes that's you they fought
them off with their crazy but they're
crazy with their eyes
all they had were their eyes
dude on their stance and their energy
like women the only way they could
protect them
it felt like you were practicing
everything in that moment
i'm just saying like they're you the 48
laws of power 101 like you
have to let people know that you are
crazy that is the only way to have any
power
is that right mm-hmm you're not a robert
green person
no that's shocking to me charlemagne is
such a robber green person yeah i feel
like i get it all i had about the
podcast
fucking mind blowing sharla no uh robert
greene
ah and what did he say what the fuck
does he know about power what powers he
had he's no but he studies
uh despots
yes he studies great powerful leaders
and how they became powerful machiavelli
my girl's coming up napoleon napoleon
she's not allowed on camera
okay can i tell her we can talk to her
but no on camera can i tell her what i
think her proposal should have been yes
i would love to be playing the wedding
okay listen this year's coming to an end
but self-care routines
still very important self-care very
important
okay this is the part right here where
whitney would ask me what what razor she
uses and then i would tell her the
answer even though we both knew the
answer already
it's the billy raiser billy b-i-l-l-i-e
they are
changing recreating everyday essentials
delivering premium razors and high
performing body care directly to you
there's no pink tax there's no visit to
the drugstore there's no breaking the
bank
you can literally get their starter kit
for nine dollars that includes
and that includes excuse me an
award-winning
razor did you even know there were
awards for razors because i sure didn't
two refillable blades and a magnetic
holder that keeps your razor
safe and dry in between uses now listen
i don't shave my legs often i know
surprise
but i say often because i have had my
legs shaved um
to get tattoos uh with one of those
little dinky razors that they use at the
tattoo shops
and let me tell you they should all get
billy razors too because i want to feel
more involved in this ad so i shave both
my legs fully and i may or may not be a
model now
and to express a little love for our
show go to mybilly.com
whitney it's a small way you can support
us while getting the best razor you'll
ever own
it's just nine dollars to get your
starter kit plus free shipping always
go to mybilly.com whitney spelled my
billy b-i-l-l-i-e dot com slash whitney
we're adults we take vitamins if you're
an adult listening to this and you don't
take vitamins give it a try what do you
why what if what if they make you live
forever you don't know until you try
okay
grow up try a vitamin ritual we've
talked about before
the thing about ritual is that they are
changing the way vitamins
are marketed does they are it's not
they're not your typical multivitamins
rituals they're clean they're vegan
friendly formulas
there may be key nutrients and forms
that your body can actually use there's
no shady extras in them
a lot of multivitamins you're not really
sure what's in them it's a little
confusing
ritual takes all the guesswork out of it
you know you're getting some that your
body can use with a clean
vegan formula and the coolest thing is
they send them right to your door
so you don't have to worry about running
out of them or going out and getting
them it makes healthier habits
super easy you deserve to know what's in
your multivitamin that's why ritual is
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months
visit ritual.com whitney to start your
ritual today
i just want i just want to say the
reason why it's officiating
the wedding dove or you i think it's
both
i think both of you guys should do it
absolutely i'm not a
i'm a bee
we don't put you on camera but if you do
want to say anything you can talk on the
mic right there
she doesn't want to come in though and
all those presents are for you right
over there
yeah the best
the best girl obsessed with you
okay when you that's my brain no put it
in front of her mouth
if this is how you're gonna co-officiate
the wedding with me this is not going to
they think that they're officiating the
wedding
i think i should do it if we have a
yeah i feel like this is the least
wedding like thing to happen
so in that case i'm okay she doesn't
want a traditional wedding yeah no you
shouldn't
yeah yeah you shouldn't i got it i'm on
it she wants to go to portland and just
sit around food trucks all day
i don't want to go to portland no can i
tell you something
hey hey hey weddings are not for you oh
right
okay they're for your friends
okay and you know what it is you know
what it is
it's not about you the wedding's not
about you
and it's also the great kevin christie
used to um come with me on the road
comedian artist
the best he said you get me
because when i was engaged i was like i
don't want to do a wedding did i he's
like i don't know
you have a wife i can't stand when you
guys are together you can't focus
i can't i'm just so obsessed with her
honestly honestly it's a problem and
that's the reason why
i can't have her at most podcasts yeah
it's almost distracting as shows
i feel like you might be able to come
here
[Music]
i feel like you have like some kind of
you might
i mean some people you don't the
forehead is
alarmingly similar some people say he
looks like my brother which is
i do i think yeah can we not ruin it
we're about to go on vacation wait
everything's like
yeah i feel like you're past life twins
or something
it's a little gross yeah um like if you
were a
girl nobody could be happy if she's not
happy no nobody can be
chilling
what do you mean you're chilling it's
falling apart what are you
talking about i'm unhinged dude i'm the
happiest
really i'm the happiest i've ever
fucking been but um
if you were a woman that's what you'd
look like right and if you were a man
that's what you look like so
really my nose would not be that bad
[Music]
and you stopped me and you had a
weddings are for your friends but i
don't want
your attention on me like i i don't okay
people got it got it but
what it is is it is about
people coming and number one seeing that
it's possible
wait real quick how many weddings have
you had
so what the fuck do you know about
weddings
okay shut up and sit down we'll take it
from here
we're the food trucks babe let's do this
before the podcast promo code whitney
why
um she took a syringe out of the fucking
fridge
it jammed it into her stomach the
peptide shit from rogan yeah
she's on the right side we're gonna
freeze the eggs too you're freezing the
eggs
i froze the eggs at 33. really so what
they're done now got 15 eggs in redondo
beach but they're done now by 30 they're
33.
no it's five years ago those eggs are
fucking toast they can hold now for 10
years no
those eggs are done in what medical
school i went to medical school which
one the bahamian one
it was a bahamian medical school and
they said if you freeze those eggs
they're fucking
they can now gelatin gelatin
those eggs are gelatin in all
seriousness
look at your eggs right now what am i
gonna give you fucking pudding so i'm
gonna i'm gonna give birth to a gummy
bear gummy bear a hundred fish said
it's gonna be shooting at you that's it
okay
hey whitney this is the love of my life
you guys look like twins
you don't look the same just as into
ancestry
look nobody can be happy
you need constitution needs to get out
there everybody could be happy
the wedding is to inspire your friends
that it is possible because half the
half these motherfuckers to come to your
wedding or to go this is not my person
i don't have that that's true
you know what i'm saying meme a meme
just happened i felt a meme just i felt
the gift just happened
like did i do that you are providing a
space where people can come and go
no i want that lizzie kaplan
bitch you're i went to her wedding and i
was like oh
oh you get to see the an example
of so people come to your wedding and go
oh
this person isn't the one
i'm gonna change i'm gonna i'm gonna ask
you a question uh
do you take corona seriously or not uh i
do my mom's in a nursing home but oh my
god
that's a that's that's a well way to
make it about you
um
she takes her mask off all the time you
do take your mask
what is the what are you asking i just
want i just want to know like what is
the responsibility with corona and
weddings because i have a friend right
oh you want to have it may not be in
this room that had a wedding in like the
height of corona uh-huh yeah how do you
feel about where where outside but the
sun kills it right
it was an inside it was an inside
wedding yeah i just do it outside
but what if it was inside really
beautiful
great speeches amazing speeches like
some of the best speeches
and uh no masks not a single mask but
what do you feel about that
and guess what nobody got corona not a
single person what
state new york take a guess um
texas florida florida
yeah no there wasn't a single case a
single case of corona but did they
get tested how do we know that they got
tested everyone at the wedding got it
both of his grandparents died three
weeks later
unrelated
i don't know what's happening mark had a
wedding
no this is 100 serious mark had a
wedding okay okay
him and alicia can i say her name okay
uh i already said it
okay they had a wedding this is height
of corones okay
we all go down there corona doesn't
exist in florida 100 convinced
does not exist well there is the sun
there's a lot of vitamin d
because people are in the sun a lot but
also la is vitamin d yeah no true but
let me ask you
yeah but are they i don't know i don't
give a fuck
dude we're comics i'm not a doctor i
don't want to be a doctor i don't want
to be a politician i don't want any of
that shit
i'm just fucking let's go down this path
i'm happy to be wrong
but are they getting tested no how do we
flick they believe
his name is garth fisher garth
good name dr garth you know he's from
garth
yes dr garth he's a he said hi my name
is
garth i'm going to put plastic in oh he
doesn't do any of that shit yes
he's he's done every tip you have jerked
off to he has done
babe sorry
i mean like i don't actually jerk off to
be honest with you
i jerked off once recently we've talked
about that before why yeah
um why you're watching when your special
came out i didn't want to have sex at 3
00 a.m when you came home from
shooting netflix yeah we were shooting a
lot i was coming home super late
you had covered i had corona
i was super hot like i was really
attracted we did fuck
how did i find out that i had corona
shit she's like i didn't get corona you
can tell this
i found out that i had symptoms when by
going down on her
because you couldn't smell her pussy and
i was like where's the flavor couldn't
taste her pussy
yeah i was like it's time for a flavor
town
it's so much heavier when she's in the
room talking like this
so and then i was like oh fuck and i ran
to the kitchen and i tried some
dried cherries no flavors yeah
take that i need a minute yeah take a
minute
okay you need a minute take a minute
take some darth in nectar take some mct
oil darfin this is the fucking shit
have you put this in your sphinx i know
no my
my sinuses are good yeah i'm not gonna
fuck with them no you you're look great
you've been drooling throughout this
episode truly no not drooling what is it
out of your nose snotting
i know i know no but that's actually oil
yeah i also put oil under my nose gotcha
okay does it look bad do i look crazy no
you look great am i the courtney love of
comedy you actually are and i wanted to
have a conversation with you about this
what what's happening what's happening
because one day you were like super glam
right and you like posted a picture and
it was just like
the brunette the hair and everything and
then the next day
um it was like honeymooners
i don't know that reference you old
fucking man god damn it
jesus christ dude don't you hate when
maybe eternal sunshine of the spot was
mine can we get like that
is that like oh my god is that a duploss
movie okay maybe we do get along
a new blast movie dude this duplos guy
that we fucking
rip apart in the special like really rip
apart it's actually funny that you do
it's actually so amazing that you do it
because you think about that was that
yours too
anthony boring instead of anthony
bourdain
anthony bourne it might it was a long
time ago but we were all writing
and was that was that yours duplass i
feel like it would have been
anyway he keeps telling bobby lee when
we're on the podcast
who the duploss you're on the whole time
he's texting bob
you're on bobby's and he's texting him
and i just drove me crazy i've never met
the guy
have you had any has anyone said like
what the fuck dude
so far to me um personally no
i mean obviously the bloggers are out
there like okay complaining yeah no no
like that's what
that's good that's good you're such
idiots because
we literally say in the piece right
we're like this is how media works
in the show that they're reviewing we go
the no name bloggers blog something
the news stations react to the no name
blogger and make it a real story when
it's not
and then the bloggers react to that and
literally
no name bloggers are reviewing the
special they're not even self-aware
enough to know
that they're doing the thing that we
called out and we're sitting back going
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much
i appreciate this because when you say
something's horrible
everybody goes oh my god that's a bad
boy i got to watch it thank you
thank you very much dude no one
understand like
the show that everyone trashed me on the
nbc show
it you're upset about this nbc show i
know i'm just saying well that was just
like
it was such a big wound yeah why because
you're rich dude you fucking made it i
was so funny like who cares i was the
calm suck dude i know it was imagine you
were doing a sitcom
like for five years imagine just spent
five years doing a sitcom i was so like
publicly she everyone tried to like
comment me so hard
hollywood because hollywood hates me
that's the thing yeah i get it
you know they should everyone thinks i'm
like hollywood person but
but that goes back to why my hair is
blue i think the confluence of
pandemic yeah uh i realized that like
hollywood doesn't really fuck with me i
i don't play their game i'm too tall i'm
too loud i'm too nasal
i'm too um ambitious they don't like it
i want too much
uh i try too hard they don't like it
so i don't get cast and stuff i'm not
like the girl next door i'm not like
the actress do you want to do that i i
don't but i'm but i'm saying
once i i but i kept going like oh i
gotta pair up with this person and this
amazing director and this amazing
producer and like
they're gonna legitimize me and and then
you and rogan and pressuring me to do
like podcasts and all that
you're like oh i don't need any of that
and then once i realized i was like oh
i've just been living in a way
to try to get the guy from high school
to like me
like i've been or like daddy it's like
it makes no sense anything
hollywood is daddy daddy daddy daddy do
you love me yeah
and i've been like daddy daddy did you
like me now do you like me now and i've
been like am i getting invited to the
party i've been
standing by waiting to get picked fuck
it
keep and then i was just like fuck a
dude well i dyed my hair because um
the i mean hair and makeup people are
losing their
i mean they're losing their health
insurance yeah so don't go to tom cruise
thing right now so i just had to do the
tom cruise thing right now
are you gonna go on a rant are you gonna
do a tom cruise i just i said what's the
most expensive thing you can do do it
really why but you still made them work
you wouldn't just give them money for
free you're like you're going to work
for it
well yeah people i don't think people
want free money yes they do people want
to earn it no they want free money
disagree
they want free money like people don't
go i don't want free money
nobody said that ever mm-hmm they're
never like we should not have free money
have you ever
given someone free money yeah how'd it
go uh they accepted it they're like
thank you very much and then how did
your relationship
with them go they were homeless person
they didn't they didn't have a home oh
oh yeah so i have given people money
just here's money yeah and then they
hate you it's only a matter of time
before they start hating you
so that they don't have to pay back well
because then you're like you're this
cloud hanging over their head and every
time they show up it's like oh new
sneakers okay
so but if you say hey dude i would love
for you to come like watch my dogs and
house sit for me
and like this and i believe shit this is
how you're charitable to your friends
you have them do
they have to overpay them you're like
lebron james i have to earn it oh thank
you
no but that's what these athletes do
like they make their friend like you
know you have to earn it
they want to earn it people oh my god
people need to
have pride yes that is right and when
you're right you're right dude you're
right thank you
you're wrong all right all right all
right all right all right all right
all right according to hollywood i am
all right when did you do anything that
was all right
but you no i just it's because i like
defend jokes people think i'm like all
right
yeah it's uh it's a little bit absurd
we're gonna plan your wedding and then
we're gonna forgive people
okay let's do it i think okay so also
the wedding is a
we're oh we're we're hiring an elephant
for the wedding
it's a cool thing i will actually it's
honestly it's a cool thing that will be
what breaks us uh honestly this is a
tradition it's like a
very like a hindu tradition my buddy
akash who does broadcast with me
right he's my best friend you're not
hiring an elephant this is no this is
part of what they do
and do this but do you keep doing your
bed i'm i'm not it's not
doing your bed we're hiring the
elephants i'll subtit i will subtitle
this and post it
so so we come in on the elephant right
and instead of instead of like the
elephant like
bending down so we get off what happens
is they just slice off each one of their
legs
i hate talking about cancel culture it's
it's stupid the fact that we acknowledge
it is ridiculous
yep it's fun it's like clickbaity and
shit yeah but it's also it's just like
gossip it's high school gossip it's like
we get dopamine and adrenaline from it
yeah we're sports reporters yes it's
it's do you think there's any logic in
cancel culture um online got worse
when sports was taken away yeah i think
everything got worse when sports was
taken away
in life in general yeah we lost our
ability to have the roman coliseum
yeah yeah what do they say give them
bread and circus or something
yeah yeah yeah
i think that's it we need to just need
to give people an excuse to get by and
then enough distraction
yeah i think that's the reason why like
people are so upset about what's
happening right now
specifically with lockdown it's just
it's not
we just don't have enough things to do
right like if they took away something
else if they limited our ability to do
something that like
didn't affect our distraction we'd be
okay but eating out is
integral in like so many people's lives
like it's a ritual it
for me it's how i socialize like i'm not
going to a fucking marquee the nightclub
right like i'm just going to go out to
dinner with my boys and go out to dinner
with my girl
that's just what i do i don't even think
i don't even know how to socialize
another way
i would go so far as like if we're not
at work and socializing that way
it's just food hey you want to meet up
and get some food wanted me to get some
drinks
how did you know your girl was your girl
um
the moment when did i like like i
remember you said
when uh you were first talking about her
it was so different like i felt it like
i i knew
like i feel like your guy friend's
platonic girlfriends know first
because you talked different about her
and you said something you were like
she i was talking on the phone about
something
and she was like oh let's not talk about
that
now so we have something to talk about
when you get home yeah yeah
right it was something like that yeah
yeah and she you were like so impressed
that she was like
siphoning out her like i want to have
things to talk to you about like
throughout our day you know yeah and
like what happens if you get there and
you were like proud
you were like so impressed by that
because i remember like when we were
first um
becoming friends you were like there's
no wives out there and it was like blew
my mind
yeah and uh i'm just i'm fascinated by
why why when i mean for me
for me it was like i wanted somebody
that i could feel
when did you know a specific day i want
to know yes
well i was a bit of a coward at first
because i was
unsure that this thing existed yeah so i
was like
super concerned to like get in and fully
kind of
um commit i
commit verbally to her right verbally
like i was committed
physically and emotionally before i was
verbally committed because i had to go
through this like trial period with my
own mind
where i was just like okay i'm in a
relationship but i'm not gonna tell her
that how soon were you monogamous
like how soon were you together i mean
pretty early yeah
like you kind of it pretty early i mean
like for me
i just kind of wanted to hang out with
her so there wasn't really any
need to like hang out with other people
and then
just kind of kind of happen organically
it wasn't like a conversation where she
was like yo stop seeing people
and i think like if you have to have
that conversation
yeah like i think it does it happens but
it doesn't have to happen like in the
first
second like i think if you're truly
getting to know somebody mm-hmm
you don't know who they are are
immediately no it takes years
years or it could take longer and by the
way yeah they're growing and changing
yeah so
hopefully you guys are going to grow
together yeah hopefully
you're never going to know who each
other are all the time because you're
changing okay yeah and improving
yeah but so yeah for me it was just like
oh wow i really like sharing with this
person
and i don't like that with everybody and
um
you know obviously she's beautiful and
all these things but it's also like um
sharing being able to share my life
people forget that love is like not
about
them how they feel about you it's about
how you feel when you're with them
yeah are you the best version of
yourself when you're with them
you have nothing to prove i'm not
performing i want to yeah i want to say
yeah but then i'm also like the most
disgusting person when i'm with her
how so i mean i'll just i i mean you're
pretty
fucking pig but i'm also what does that
mean
i just i realize it i mean like can i
tell the thing yeah like i lost my sense
of smell
you know obviously because of corona and
um i like i'll scratch my butt a lot
like my hole my actual
butthole yeah and uh and then usually
i'll do like a little taste
not taste test so smell test and i'll
just just to see if there's doodle on my
finger everyone does that yeah that's
very normal
but i lost my sense of smell so i went
for the smell
and i forgot i lost my sense of smell
and i go i was like oh that doesn't
smell like shit at all
and then i go to spoon her and i cuddle
her up and then i just hear her go
get up what is that did you stuff your
fist in your ass
and i lit i go i don't know what
happened and like my whole hand just
smelled like a shit
and i literally had put it right under
her nose like dirty sanchez almost
what how how many weeks or months this
is a month ago
but uh but yes yeah being i feel like i
didn't have to like you know like put on
anything there's like a primal
comfort there's a comfort there's also
like a curiosity and then like for me
would have to pee
in front of each other yeah yeah poop
she caught me wiping the other day and
that was too much
she got me wiped like she walked by yeah
the door was open
you look at your shit after that was
what you caught me doing it wasn't
wiping it was looking at it
yeah how do you know when it's done you
don't you know wipe are you a fucking
maniac you just wipe and then think
there's no poop left
and then walk around every day i feel
well i actually i'm gonna blow your mind
crazy person
i'm gonna blow your mind oh my god if i
know that i'm going to have to have
anal yeah new york sometimes i'll put my
finger in my butthole and scoop out poop
yeah you have to go there
you got to go there no you got to go
there push it back up you push it back
and pack it in like you can just like
scoop it out you can go in and scoop it
out and like people like packaging yeah
[Laughter]
okay you guys know that i'm an athlete i
do athletic things okay i drink athletic
greens
which is the most comprehensive daily
nutritional beverage i've ever had
they take all the guesswork out of
trying to maintain effective nutritional
habits because listen we're busy we have
a lot of things to do
we have tv shows to watch we have busy
schedules we have a lot of sleeping
sometimes we don't even do that good
it's too much work so they take a lot of
the guesswork out of it
they can help you because their
all-in-one superfood powders
are your nutritional essentials one
tasty scoop of athletic greens tasty one
tasty scoop
of athletic greens contain 75 vitamins
minerals and whole food source
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more
they all work together to fill in the
nutritional gaps in your diet i have a
lot
and increase energy and focus aid in
digestion and support a healthy immune
system
which is great because i know we're all
sick of some stuff that's
wonderful simply visit athletic
greens.com whitney and join health
experts athletes and health conscious
go-getters around the world
who are making a daily commitment to
their health every day
daily and every day guys again simply
visit athleticgreens.com
whitney and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs today that's
awesome
listen we all love coffee i'm sure
that's a generalization but
it's the truth and if you like coffee
you will
adore super coffee okay isn't it
indulgent healthy ready to drink
alternative to sugary coffee drinks
it's made to power you the entire day it
uses a combination of caffeine
healthy fats proteins and you don't have
that jittery growth
like after caffeine filling and i mean
they have so many different products too
like i know that i have
the creamer i have uh the mochas the
espresso shots the
the whole bean coffee and they're
everyone that i've tried has been
delicious i'm obsessed with them the
coconut mocha
super coffee positive energy sweet and
creamy beverage and the little tall can
if it comes in a can you can't see it i
know but you could like google it
it's wonderful wonderful
they're plant-based there's zero sugar
added they're keto which i know people
are really into that that's like a
keyword for you
you'll love this coffee and we've worked
out an exclusive deal for the good for
you podcast listeners where you can
receive
25 off plus free shipping on any
of super coffee's best selling variety
packs this is a great way to try all
their delicious favors
go to drinksupercoffee.comwhitney and
use the code whitney at checkout to
claim this deal
that's d-r-i-n-k-s-u-p-e-r-c-o-f-f-e-e
dot com slash whitney super coffee is
also available nationwide in over 25 000
stores like target whole foods walmart
kroger and cvs
okay well i guess i should have knew
about it earlier then i don't know why
how i missed it
it's wonderful go get it so here's it so
for me it was like
it was that and then also weird things
started to happen were like things that
i was like super specific about
mm-hmm like i had like these
idiosyncrasies you know like i was
really not i did not like certain things
tell me example like uh
like no toenail polish on women
like i like polish on the nails okay and
when it was just flush it was like gross
to me
and you don't like toenail polish no i
do like toenail polish you need the
toenail polish oh yeah yeah
when it's the toenails are fucking nasty
but here's the thing
so i'm like i need that's a thing are
you into toes
my feet i like feet a lot boomerang yeah
i like feet i don't like doing anything
sexual with them i just think it's a
pretty part of the female body
yeah yeah that's a um there's an
interesting
um yeah it's like the brain is like the
foot part is right next to the sex part
or something so the white there's also a
um
theory that uh when we're babies and
we're crawling around
and our moms walked barefoot around we
ah
that's interesting ask your mom if she
was barefoot a lot walking around you're
crawling and seeing her toes
interesting yeah that might be a case
yeah it's possible
anyway so yeah like i just started
noticing things that like i used to
think i really cared about
and then all of a sudden like i didn't
really care that much
i it was it became like yes or no
to like yeah preference and i was like
oh shit i thought
this was like a hard line yeah yeah the
things that i used to think were hard
and fast rules are now
suddenly malleable and then i'm like oh
they were never
hard and fast tries to pretend to be
stupid as like his
i don't think you have a schtick but you
like to pretend you're stupid for some
reason i think malleable is a stupid one
i think you need to release it is
malleable stupid that word no it's a big
word that's big for you if i
said malleable you would clown on me no
i would
i wouldn't when you said didactic why is
didactic any
that's tape pour that coffee on your
head
and you said didactic i want to take it
and then turn it upside down try me
come up with a word i won't know um
kind i don't think i'm kind
of teasing defenestrate defend it
straight
defenestrate defenestrate what does it
mean
a sentence the pentacon is the defender
strait of the united states of america
but do you think you'll run for office
no never i think it's
i think i wouldn't either yeah i
wouldn't either i think you can move
culture way better without
being in politics concur but i think
that the people that
won't run should run yes 100 and i think
if you want if there is a point about
canceled culture do you want to bring up
that isn't just like
us comedians crying that we can't do
jokes i think that you'll never have
well not never but like you're not going
to have the right person for the job
to be president because they're going to
go through their lives and find out
they said something rude to somebody in
and then that's going to make them
complete they're going to completely
eviscerate their character they're gonna
make them so radioactive that they're
like i don't even want to be part of
this
and i think that now we're just gonna
get like mike pence's of the world
right who just are clean but you're
clean so you got no flavor
you know trump was an anomaly in that
regard he was just like yo yeah i'm a
fucking piece of shit what's up
is trump gonna go on brogan i think he
should
100 he should 100
yeah you don't want to hear him talk
when he's like you got nothing to lose
you don't hear him just fucking talk
that shit is he gonna run again
he's old i don't think so it's too much
yeah it's too much
yeah you gotta listen to the silvio
berlusconi thing he's good
he's the man he he basically silvio is
berlusconi prime minister of italy like
he he's the mafia guy right yeah
yeah every um did he believe the dark
just hits me in the neck
if people believe in what they say
why am i not all people obviously you
can take this out of context whatever
but like if people really believe in
their shit and they truly believe like
what they're doing is like
is the right thing and helping um
there's a little bit more respect for
that even if you disagree with it
when somebody's like a grifter they're
just latching onto a movement so that
they can like gain
power like popularity or fame then i'm
just repulsed by you and you're
disgusting
should podcasts be funny or interesting
i think the funniest stuff is
interesting like to me the best
conversation is a serious one
that then veers off to funny mm-hmm you
know like like we'll have
on our podcast flagrant too right like
we'll have these conversations that are
like start in a serious place
and then they just become the most
absurd
crazy conversation yeah and that's the
funny to me but like
because if it's all just like slapstick
after a while it's just like
is there anything that you've that
you're like oh hope that doesn't start
getting a trend circulated oh like of
mine
like a clip i'm sure i'm sure i've said
i mean like i've talked
like old stuff for me it's more unfunny
jokes
of my old stand up like my first carson
daly set
i was fortunate enough to like not have
those opportunities was fortunate enough
to get rejected by hollywood early yeah
so i so i don't have to it's 100
you're actually kind of clean yeah that
way not clean but like i'm clean from
like my worst shit
right because i started putting out my
stuff and obviously i'm only going to
put out the
what i felt was the best at the time now
there might be some way earlier clips so
i'm like this wasn't good but like
i waited so long to put things out
because i was like oh maybe i'll get an
opportunity this year maybe i'll get
and then eventually i was like she's
like fuck it but by then i'm not two
years in putting out clips
i'm 10 years in ready to go and that
one hour that took me 10 years to build
is like really sharp
so i'm not as concerned about that who's
the funniest comic working
working mm-hmm funny comic the funniest
kind
funniest comic ever is patrice o'neill
the funniest comic
working right now
when he wants to be funny would patrice
be funny now yeah
he'd be the best of course not a
question patrice is the goat to me
and it's not even like a close
conversation i think to me it's like
the type of comedy i like yeah he's the
floyd he's the floyd 100
100 i mean if chappelle wants to be
funny
if he wants to turn the switch on i
think he's the funniest right now
probably but um what is this new trend
where comics now have to be vulnerable
and serious and
political and sincere yeah i don't know
we gotta ask you you gotta ask dave
about that you should talk to him about
that yeah like what what the
point of it is i gotta know what do you
think it is i don't know i don't i just
i don't wanna lecture
anyone yeah me personally i just i don't
i don't
i want people when they see click on me
they know they're gonna get
santa claus it's gonna be surprising and
funny and silly and dumb and
interesting and like like a um remember
those uh
cracker jack boxes where there's a prize
yeah like i just want to
do that yeah you're a cracker jack box
thank you
yeah yeah hacker are we allowed to say
cracker
yeah okay he's okay yeah i asked the
black person in the room but that's our
word
that's our word yeah he can't get back
honky
yeah you're a honkey dude i got to start
calling white girls honking you know
about that
hysterical redneck
yeah this honky cut me off the other day
dude
etymology shit like that like redneck
and hillbilly
yeah you know like redneck actually
i don't know where it was where i said
redneck on something and um
they were asking me about cutting it and
i was like no redneck actually
like what do you think redneck means
redneck means person working in the
fields and their neck was red
why is the sun the sun interesting yeah
what it actually was
is uh the coal miners in west virginia
at the
battle of blair mountain
they wore red handkerchiefs and it was
an uprising
against the coal mining industry
corporations
and it was the second biggest battle
after the civil war
american history in west virginia so
redneck is actually a
um symbol of pride a strong motherfucker
that challenge you're a redneck
fought back again dude you're a redneck
yeah yeah
like full-on full-on redneck that then
kind of like partnered up with the
corporations only yeah yeah
and i'm just it's if you don't someone
else will if you don't someone else
if you don't someone else will as long
as we're partnering up on my terms i'm
with it who cares
and also um hillbilly
please watch the documentary on hulu by
ashley york
okay it's what is it it's about the word
hillbilly
and because you know james corden i went
on james corden's show
you know like a what you know
because of the numbers yeah huge massive
is he nice like what's his deal like i
don't get um i think he's really
nice and la he he was a theater actor
yeah and but he just wants to make
americans laugh like i think the
business
there's something weird like i get
what's the
i don't get like explain to me like i
don't have any like urge like i don't
have to like i need to move to sweden
and make
i think you just have to be 60. so it's
just money they just want money
right well i think that there's you know
like i just i'm trying to understand i
did kelly clarkson there
have you when you go to the vet
something's playing
yeah they're you know when you go to the
doctor there's a tv
when you go to the dmv there's a tv
playing it's ellen it's kelly clarkson
it's just kind of like it's just
it's candy yeah it's just candy yeah
that's it yeah that's all it is it's
innocuous
but what is the like the driving force
like the driving for it like
but i'm not trying to plug the specialty
mid that's not what i'm trying to do
it's doing fine
don't watch it um honestly don't watch
it you guys don't need to watch it it's
fine don't worry it's training number
one without you so
yeah no big deal honestly it's not a big
deal
but like the driving force like when we
were gearing up to make it
i was looking at um the sagrada familia
do you know what that is
no this is gowdy's cathedral in
barcelona i used to live in barcelona
and i would just look at images of it
images of what it's going to look like
when it's finished and i look at just
these like images i go through it
non-stop
right wow and i was like that is
a masterpiece this is a masterpiece he
died and it's still going to take
another 50 years or 60 years after his
death to complete it
but that's a masterpiece you know so i'm
going when i
when we have the opportunity to make
this show i'm like it needs to be a
masterpiece like it needs to be so
different and so incredible and every
little face of it
facet of it needs to be amazing right
okay
i i i'm not even thinking about like the
financial part of it
right that's not my motivation uh-huh i
just like how do we make a masterpiece
yes right da vinci da vinci you have
italian ancestry you must
maybe everybody thinks i am whatever
they are but that's just what it is
projection
yeah i guess but my point is like i i
don't understand
so i guess the people that are making
those kind of shows what is their
driving force it's just like i want a
bigger house like
which is fine too if you want to get
money that's great i just don't
understand what
it is i think it's addiction so fame
i think that we the what's left out of
this conversation and it was like
frustrating me when i was listening to
you and joe
talk is like no one talks about
addiction we are all
addicted to something okay so it's like
we happen to have lucrative addictions
but we don't happen to we worked very
hard but to funnel what we need into
something that we love to do
because our dopamine receptors didn't
hold dopamine the same way as other
people
unless we got an adrenaline turns into
dopamine and we're genuine addicts okay
right maybe so we were maybe a fucking
dick
um as joe would say it's entirely
possible as someone who it's entirely
possible made the female brain yeah
which andrew was in and stole the movie
and tested very highly completely stolen
dude
one scene dude i will never forget when
you went you went up to blake griffin
and you guys were improvising and you
went you smell like a pet store i used
that same reference the other day that's
so funny it was just like you smell like
a
pet store yeah because it's a visceral
smell right like
it's so specific you know exactly what
it is you know it's like
you're like you smell like a salmon like
there was
there was like a there was it was so i
remember being in post being like how do
we
make this pig how do we pick i thought
you guys did a great job
i have a i'm doing a q a on i love that
movie that movie's like getting
weirdly big now really was on planes
every time i'm on a plane i see it
that's so funny and i was like oh wow
this is probably
d i mean is that big money to be on
planes
uh uh not for me but maybe the
financiers
oh you weren't the finance here no
really i didn't get
i i put in about 50 grand to that movie
and you didn't make anything out of it
don't you get paid back as one of the
financiers no no no no
what's going on here no i lose i lost
money on that
respect that was an investment
just show people yo i got this labor of
love well no i mean i couldn't i
couldn't do it i did it
i i we had 14 days a couple of my
friends have gone q and on
yeah and watching it i watch them and i
go to their instagrams and i watch the
thing
righteous hmm like there's worse things
to join
it's like it's own religion yeah but
like there's worse religions out there
like they literally are like we should
stop pedophiles
like they're not the worst people but
yeah
a lot of people who
are in attracted that were sexually
abused yeah that's why they're drawn to
it of course
yeah i'm just saying like we and you
know in the special we have like a piece
about queuing on but like
i'm very empathetic like when we wrote
it we're like
i think we should kind of like
understand these people and not just
make fun of them
no trust me yeah yeah and because one
there's no way you're going to get them
out of it
right let them have their anesthesia
either let them have their anesthesia or
don't act like it's ridiculous to
believe
some of the things they believe like
clearly there's pedophiles like
clearly there's corruption like the
baseline beginning for it
is not in any way inconceivable what do
we do about the whole pedophile
like the problem is when it becomes what
happened is it kind of became like
white people's blm in a way like the
people that didn't support blm
they kind of went q and i think it was
because they felt like they were missing
out on a movement to help people that
weren't them
but they didn't helping people is an
addiction yes you know and you feel
righteous you self-righteous indignation
taking down
pedophilia everyone everyone wants to be
a hero yeah it's
been trained we've been trained we
watched superman we
everyone wants to be a hero yeah it's
like the abortion thing it's like the
abortion thing
it's like these people that are pro-life
they think they're saving babies because
yeah they think
they are saving babies they're saving
babies we agree
yeah we are on the same side yeah we
neither of us want to kill babies
correct
correct yeah i agree with you yes we're
the same
yeah you're fucking awesome yeah it's
it's not an evil human being yeah you
know uh
yeah it's a pretty like righteous thing
i think we did a youtube piece when we
were doing the show for like instagram
and youtube
and we just did like we were making fun
of like epstein and galen and shit and
um
the reaction to it was great but there
was also this reaction like yo thank you
for talking about these things it was
it wasn't just funny it was like you're
really doing the right thing
and i and i was like oh that's how
people can kind of get caught in this
vacuum
is they're getting these pats on the
back for being like a good human being
and that's intoxicating to someone who's
never had like positive support
or reward so i could see how you get
caught up in it you with the
giraffe thing to go back to that's you
you're a q a
for giraffes you're a you are q and on
for animals
um what is that that's my 12-step
program i'm in
you don't drink no uh al-anon is for
uh adult children of alcoholics adult
children of alcoholics if you grew up
and your parents were alcoholic
but everybody's parents were alcoholic i
know for alcohol
yeah parents weren't alcohol correct and
for alcohol to be present
alcoholism to be present alcohol doesn't
have to be present
so it could be crafting cleaning cooking
perfectionism
control you know there's lots of
addiction sex yeah
you know i grew up around a lot of sex
addiction a lot of you know that shit
um why why are you throwing me off track
your giraffes you're drafting on oh um
that's the thing with giraffes why keep
going you're a giraffe none you want to
save the giraffes
keep going it's a righteous thing to
save the giraffes oh no god complex yeah
so there's something called founder
syndrome
so a lot of people that start how many
syndromes do you know
like how many could you name like if you
just had to just start naming syndromes
like i got one what are your notes on my
podcast down how can i be better
the only one i got am i bombing this no
you're great you
are great because you just have the
personality for it like
people you don't realize this about
yourself or maybe you're just realizing
it but like people enjoy you
like emma i don't even like saying your
name but i've said your name on this
right
jesus i think i have right she didn't
ask for it give her a fake name
angelica that's one thing i protect her
because she didn't ask her she doesn't
want the attention so it's like i'm not
gonna put that on her yeah
but um but like she doesn't listen to
podcasts
she'll watch your clips on instagram
she'll like share your clips on
instagram
she just finds you funny people find you
funny they enjoy you they want to be
around you why you seem so shocked
you're shocked you were shocked by it i
don't understand that's probably why you
didn't do it for so long that's what in
my mind that's why i imagine you didn't
do it for so long
you're probably like oh people aren't
going to like me if i'm just talking i
have to like script something perfectly
i know yeah
yeah yeah i have a uh like well i think
you don't get funny by thinking you're
funny
yeah you have to i have a constitute
like in my
well my i have a i have a theory on that
i have like a cellular
uh fear of being boring
so you overcompensate by being like
really entertaining i think
well everyone was drunk growing up you
had to be entertaining you had to keep
everybody happy and i was always the
party play i gotta get keep everybody up
you're good we're good
you gotta read the room you gotta be a
shapeshifter oh you want me to shine you
want me to not shine you have to like be
able to be a chameleon
you have to be able to like what do you
need how do i you need a drink
too many drinks one more like you just
have to kind of referee everything be an
octopus yeah yeah
yeah and that's and then you're
a comedian and then you're a heckler
heckler but i get it you have to feel
everyone's energy all the time these
this couple's fighting
this is a bad marriage it's a bad date
yeah these are brothers
they're tourists i mean one time i had
this crazy thing
i was on in the or um
uh like a couple years ago and there was
this guy in the front and i looked at
him
and i was like you look like you're from
like copenhagen
he's like i'm from copenhagen it was
like we
we do have this kind of ability to
um whether it's inherited or whatever to
like feel
people mm-hmm yeah we're sensitive yeah
incredibly hyper vigilant sensitive
yeah i mean like yeah it's i think it's
the most valuable asset for a comic is
not like being sensitive to like
somebody's word but like
how somebody feels like i i like feeling
how the room
is and like you have to it's a
superpower because you're getting
you're it's not hurting sheep it's
you're hypnotizing i mean you're getting
it's so funny i was just trying to write
it's hurting attention and it's not like
the actual people but like it's hypnosis
it's mass hypnosis yeah
it's not hypnosis because like hypnosis
means like you're not in control but
like
it's putting people in a situation where
you know how much patience they'll give
you and then trying to for me at least
trying to stretch that patience as far
as you can because
the biggest laugh is going to come at
the very tip of that patient
right it's like i can wait i can wait i
can wait i can wait yeah and then if you
make you wait too long it's like all
right i'm getting a little bored waiting
then it's like they kind of know the
formula now so i got to switch it up
yeah you also have to know it's
basketball i mean that's basketball
yeah that's boxing embarrassing how i
just played outside and i was terrible
about it no
no no i was very good at basketball
growing up and
i think we've just been practicing in
the studio we have this little
basketball hoop and it
looks like there's nothing you can
there's nothing you can say all right i
i mean this is just paris it was like
honestly i felt like
i have i it was uncomfortable to say
something i felt uncomfortable i feel
uncomfortable now
i i told you a story about when i have
shit on my fingers
and i didn't know did not feel
uncomfortable now i feel uncomfortable
i feel i'm hot i feel
so uncomfortable right now because
that's why she came later i was like i
need to get some warm up in and then it
was like uh
like i mean it was bad it was short
every single time i mean no it was like
it was like a granny it was really bad
it was not good at all but here's the
thing
this is a fear of mine i hate baseball
okay you don't hate anything uh you're
right but it's just better to be more
passionate yeah yeah
like if we speak reasonably about our
feelings it's boring yeah yeah yeah
i have a lukewarm opinion of baseball
right like
you know i here's why i fuck with baby
paul oh god it's the most boring sport
on the planet okay but i like that you
could be like 40 and fat
yeah and eat you can consume food i like
doing it yeah like these old like
just racist fat news playing ball like
they play one every four games that's it
yeah
like it's just such a ridiculous it's so
dumb it's absurd
but i have a fear that if i don't
continue to practice
throwing a ball uh-huh that when i have
my child and i want to play catch with
him
her or her they them zim
elliott elliot when i'm playing catch
with elliott
right i'll throw like a girl
if i don't continue to work the arm
there is a and can i tell you i think
podcasting
terrifying seeing a dad play catch with
their kid
and throwing like a girl there is a
imprint in us yeah is
the need to pass her boobs did you see
that i do that i know i do it
is
and i have like a bandage so
what was that what was the mold is going
like this what's that
do you know that what soup come on guy
what is her star
what is it what happens she smells her
armpits oh i always do
oh god guys guys guys guys guys stop it
they smell awful which means i don't
have covered
and you can't smell it anyway i stopped
using deodorant even though the aluminum
thing a doctor just told me that's
bullshit yeah of course they're not
putting aluminum in deodorant yeah they
do that lumen's expensive
um
did you taste it do i look down no i
don't taste i don't taste i've tasted
boogers before but not my
of course um i do have bo but i just
it's fine
none of you were platonic okay
where were we yet dove could crack those
cheeks wide open
did you see the new exercise i'm doing
to get a big butt
wait a minute did you mute me what the
fuck what
did you meet me yeah i muted you jesus
christ no i didn't mute you why
because my uh uh stories you don't watch
my stories
i do watch your story i told him that we
have the same dermatologist
so dr lancer you go to dr lancer yes i
have forever
dr lancer is my like dad slash
side piece but i saw your your butt
jiggling thing in your
yeah i did um i started doing this
machine
that jiggles your exercises your butt
for you
mm-hmm okay so that
it's equivalent to 20 000 squats okay
so get ready dove dove
get ready after this what after we after
we cold let me tell you something that
thing is cracking back okay
she might crack you wide open with that
thing
okay
on the first episode that i came on here
it's tricky you can also do it on your
abs as well yeah i've seen it
so that i did that thing yeah um it was
good though but i
uh the wedding no what was the where
were we
um you were saying that the netflix
special is a masterpiece
unbelievable this has been such a like
smooth feels jazz roll out yeah oh wait
for the special i thought you were
talking about us
yes like that too this podcast yeah yeah
we have some kind of weird
thing no it's just comfort dude yeah
it's all good
i know remember when we did that podcast
with neil brennan how awkward that was
no i thought it was really funny oh
really
yeah i thought i left there being like
oh i bombed that no
i thought i felt like his clips were
great i feel like i disappointed you
inside jokes no
you no you were great it was fun but i
think what it is it's like
like when you're caught when you're
around somebody you're like oh it's
going to be funny
you're just not that stressed and then
when you got stressed it ends up being
funny yeah
but you know when you're like carrying
the weight of something you're like oh
fuck i gotta have
what's the next question how do i do
this yeah and you're trying to impress
others
that's the thing about comedians is like
what's so funny about podcasts is we
don't
we we're not fake with each other
everyone thinks we don't
we're not funny when we're together this
is the only time we don't have to be
funny
yeah okay this is we're off duty
we're off duty now we get to be it's
like a comedian i get to finally be
fucking serious
james so i sucked at podcasting because
i was like i feel like i'm boring as
shit because
i'm talking to bill burr i'm not gonna
do bits for bill burr yeah
i'm not gonna bomb in my in front of two
people
yeah in front of bill like i've done
that before in the fucking belly room
yeah did you watch the comic store
documentary no
was it really good i i don't doesn't
matter were you in it
i was yeah and what what what happened
it's
you'll just watch it and i'd love to see
what you think do i have to watch it no
okay no without you know i mean like you
don't watch anything huh
not really it's hard i don't like
watching comedy stuff
yeah it's just like oh wait whatever the
other funny comedian you ever told me
patrice and then you said there was one
more that was coming the funniest comic
or just like if you were like gun to
your head yeah
who's the fucking special fucking
someone in
is like under your head i need someone
to make me laugh what special should i
watch a special
i better fucking laugh a special or a
comic
special or a thing what's gonna make me
fucking laugh under your head
there's a comic he's a he's a trans
comic
robin tran no he's uh he's his name is
mark gagnon
okay he is gunned to your head you will
laugh 100
guaranteed guaranteed brilliant like i
mean
comics are were dead inside brilliant
yeah no no honestly unbelievable
i had to nicki glazer was here the other
day i don't know if he has any stuff
out but he literally he just
created and wrote this netflix thing and
uh it's really it's fucking unbelievable
people are saying it's like sagrada
familia
like wait is this the thing that's the
where
are you that's mark right there
wait okay
why prank me why
[Laughter]
why why by the way bitch
you love acting you love acting no i
love
acting okay you love it acting's corny
all you fucking do is ask
live experience live experience you want
a comic live
this is going to be a ragnon is your
last name
what a fucking what what's that no it's
it's it's gagnon
like gangnam style yes exactly
it's a it's a korean last name what is
that
what i've never heard that no it's
french french canadian
yeah yeah from montreal yuck
[Laughter]
but he's very funny concur yeah big fan
one of the biggest korean comedians out
there huge massive
in korea massive yeah
they're fucking dying what like makes
you laugh huh what makes you laugh
honestly um this is
this is like if it the thing that
probably makes me laugh the most
like if somebody i know really well is
like
clearly like pretending to impress
somebody
yeah shit i've been fucking even
thinking about it
he might be in this room but he might
not be and one time we were at a
nightclub he might have directed this
special on netflix right now he might
have
and uh he might have done that he might
be the director and
um one time we're at this like club in
l.a
and there's this girl that he was
hitting on and this girl was like a
legit
six foot girl right very attractive six
foot girl
and this guy he's i'm saying like on a
good day
5 10. good day good day
a pair of timberlands okay wedge heels
you know red shield or five ten right
but this guy
had found that's the place of delilah
you know delilah
delilah's delilah's whatever he found a
place where there was a tiny step
in delilah and it was and it was yep and
it was by the way that's what
scientologists do
they always have to be taller a little
bit well yeah yeah yeah so tom cruise
will like set stand on the curb and wear
a platform exactly so he found a little
step
and i watched him move the conversation
over to the step so he could be taller
and step
on the step and then he had one foot on
the step and the other foot
is literally pointed down and drag it
barely touching the floor
and he is spitting game and balancing
for his
life like he'd make her laugh and she'd
like she'd like bump his shoulder and
he'd literally like
sway it just sway
back and forth like a grandfather clock
so to me there is nothing funnier than
like catching a friend of mine close
friend of mine
doing something like faking something
faking something to impress somebody
else i will fucking cry
i will cry laughing oh god yeah watching
watching your friend act yes watching a
friend act
is the best thing in the world i can't
stop laughing i just i just howl
laughing
i would fall on the ground and roll
around on the ground that is
so funny yeah it's it's like what's the
things
okay so that's made me laugh what made
me laugh uh
benton came over one day uh to try to
cheer me up
when i was in a tight spot uh dressed as
a bee
that's hot i seen that outfit and he got
stung by me hilarious
wow why he
and then he tried to quit he was like i
quit i quit i'm not doing this anymore
he tried to quit and i wouldn't let him
quit
hilarious i mean that is that was like i
was like crying
crying laughing and then another time
the the last time i the artist i've
laughed
recently is um my you know my first job
was a
uh uh my first stand-up set was on a
show called last call with carson daly
yeah yeah yeah i did that show and then
i was a writer oh i got you that job you
did
fuck dude thank you man my manager said
that he did it
i had no clue you did that i can't
believe
he took total credit you didn't know
that yeah i had no clue
i had no clue that's amazing that's what
they'll do it's okay i fired him
wow thank you what is better than like
the fucking family when comics like
support each other yeah i'm surprised
you didn't ask for the credit you must
thought i was a douche not saying thank
you
i don't i don't need the credit yeah i
want the funny people to win
i don't everybody yeah i just feel it
doesn't help
jamie yeah managers push unfunny people
yeah
comics only comics know who's funny yeah
who are these bookers that decide who's
funny it just doesn't make any sense
they used to have like a system where
they could just do that there was like a
guy that went to advertising school who
would pick
the comics yeah but that used to work
because the system like the structure
was so perfect
that like you could put almost anybody
in it and they had all the power
like the people just should have the
power just like some random person on
the street
they should go to a comedy club and just
go like do who do you think is funny
they do now look at us
like a stranger yeah strangers decide
strangers have always decided now we
just have the ability to get to the
strangers
the last time i laughed so hard is um i
had a thanksgiving
and uh that was my first job i was a
writer on that show
so i was also pitching comics to nicole
yaren
booker um who now does the fucking voice
and she's a beast
yeah and uh she goes um i was like
remember when carson daley used to wear
a live strong bracelet
and she goes oh he still does
today no cars daily
today does he still paint two nails
still he painted two of his nails
was that a thing yeah he still wears a
lift short bracelet you gotta love it
on the today show but yeah like why did
we stop caring about cancer
coney 2012 i paid for that i swear to
god i got the dvds and everything sort
of got out of my life
coney 2012 i swear to god i got the d
joseph coney was a like evil dictator in
some african
country and um some kids in san diego
decided that it was up to them to get
him the fuck out of here so they put out
some video maybe it was on youtube or
something like i don't know where i saw
i was on youtube
and um they're like you can go support
we're gonna raise all this money and i
fucking it worked and i was like i gotta
fight the good fight
and then that kid i think they made him
go crazy
he randomly was just running naked in
san diego
but naked and then they shut that whole
thing down but i literally think and i'm
not like the big conspiracy guy but like
i think the american government was like
yo too many people want us to do
something we don't want to do
yeah so let's get rid of this leader
let's just make him look like a maniac
and he was found
running butt naked in san diego and then
after that they just shut the whole
thing and then
where did the money was there where
where'd your money go i don't know but i
got like stickers
we were putting the stickers up it's
really wild
how we are such what is that
schools of fish what is it when you yeah
i think i was a little bit more
i think i was a uh i think i was that
but the contrarian version we're so
emotional
yeah but like so there's some people
that like just gravitate towards what
everybody's doing
and i went through this phase where like
i equally gravitated to the opposite of
what everybody was doing
yeah i'm like that right so it's like i
was equally always devil's advocate yeah
always that was advocate but i
i thought that i was being like unique
and different but i was equally alarming
just in the opposite direction i was
easily manipulatable so like it took me
a while to kind of go oh no you should
actually pick the direction you go
yeah and it's also i think the days of
like if you it used to be when
people disagreed it was an interesting
conversation
and now you're like an asshole mm-hmm
you know what i mean
yeah like i just this is why i don't
fuck with people that aren't comics
because
i love to grapple yeah emotionally
like that's how my family was yeah
that's your comfort zone that's why i
love roseanne because
i wanted to bring it back is that they
were like trashing
roasting each other yeah my family
roasted each other yeah constantly
yeah clowning each other's hair head
lice cooking all of it
it's lice what happened to lice my dude
headlights
yeah kids used to get lice all the time
every year pink eyes
i had head lice i used to fucking pull
bugs out of my hair like in class
really yes that's gross dude yeah nyx
member no rit rit rit and nyx those were
the
um medicines you'd have to use i didn't
know i never got it remember john
roberts
the north carolina senator or whatever
john roberts was running for president
like he had a girl that he was fucking
on the side
no yes i got exposed so john roberts
this was like the first guy that did
youtube
videos the christmas tree video you ever
seen this
let me see okay so this guy did a spell
okay did i drink it though is there
anything with flavor
drink it yeah it's strawberry okay so
this is my favorite video
i watch it i know it all by heart
this was in what is it 2004 2004
this guy john roberts what is mct oil i
just need to know
you're friends with rogan you should
know what is it do we know what that is
it's if it's a it's the uh goji berry
oh so i'm good acai berry that's it it's
like a
whatever i can drink it and it's not
anything crazy oh no okay
i'll keep going just start shitting
immediately
so no but i want you to really watch
this because this is important to me
okay
this is
sorry oh wait wait hold on the volume's
not um
why not mute it's on mute unmute mute
volume
how come i can't play this um maca
can you help me what's going on here oh
oh
sounds off sorry that's me okay did you
all see that
sorry mark make fun of me with the
technology stuff
i just i'm like my brain is not okay
ready see
hurry up we're going to get the tree
come on
come on we just got the tree we just got
the tree it's gorgeous
yeah come on you got to see it we just
got the tree
you got to see oh look at how long is
this if it says
how long ago is this 2004. so this is
this is pause this is
shit mom's say shit dad say shit persian
say
this is the precursor interesting yeah
that and they've tried to make a sitcom
they did one with uh shatner
but no no no no no yeah yeah i remember
that twitter account but what i'm saying
is like
you know how those videos will go viral
like uh what is it i don't know how to
describe it but like um things persian
people saying
all the things that like stereotypically
turned into memes yeah like
your mom on christmas we're going to get
the tree yeah yeah it's cool to see like
the first iteration of that this is like
the fir this is like
the original youtube like tick tock like
this is like
um john roberts you love this guy
love so what happened to him this is
like my um
mr rogers or so like i can't explain it
on a bojack horseman now like he's a
voice what
we're going to get the train yeah come
over now playing his mom hurry up
we're going to get the tree come on come
on we just got the tree
we just got the tree it's gorgeous yeah
come on you got to see it
we just got the tree
look at that tree hey if it says tree on
it that means
decorations it needs to come down yeah
yeah we're going to decorate the tree
come over make it nicer around the tree
come on make it even make it nice come
on
what's happening right now don't turn on
the tree don't turn it on
go ahead turn it on
[Music]
[Applause]
are you pranking me right now no i just
want you to watch it
got away from the tree please would you
get away from the tree
this is what's interesting okay so
because i think john roberts
was kind like you too so
this look at this
so this when he started doing this
youtube at whatever this
timing is that was the cover
thumbnail thumbnail so he started
putting good thumbnails so
he at this smart time code he would
always have
oh like a eye catching this is before
you could personalize thumbnails
correct that is brilliant i know that is
absolutely brilliant so this is on some
andrew schultz shit
whoa so he knew that
this was going to get more views than a
woman in a wig or a christmas tree
oh my god he found a way to hack yes the
system so he knew
that at the time they pulled like
whatever it
point 56 seconds that's pretty that's
the image they would use the thumbnail
so that is fucking brilliant accordingly
because this makes no sense but now
you're like okay
i got to see why this guy is you know
interesting
[Music]
because this is that's nobody it's not
this is breaking character
and not as funny as the other stuff and
you spoke to him about this
i'm trying to have him on next year yeah
that's really good isn't that wild
that's really smart so he sort of was
the first person to like
now when we're always trying to like
hack the algorithm and get an algorithm
you know
that's what we did in netflix yeah we
hacked it
okay let me just can we just finish it
yeah but then i want to tell you what we
did
why isn't the tree on come on turn on
the tree please for me
turn on the tree and pick up all that
shit
hey come on everyone we're gonna take a
picture by the train everyone get in the
dead come on hey
what are you doing i'm taking place
right at the tree inside right now
what's bailey's help me clean up
the tree please such a mess
tree
[Music]
next to you pick that up
bye train
so that was 2004. that's great really
smart though to think about that
the way that it's cut the way that it's
the way that it like hits your emotions
there's just something interesting about
what it's great head of his time yes
sometimes what happens is um
i've probably given this analogy before
but like uh are you familiar with dog
town and z boys the skateboarders
i am there was a movie made of yeah they
were like the first like real
street skateboarders they were like go
to these pools and people's backyards
that have been emptied
yeah yeah in the 70s uh maybe it was the
70s
in san francisco or no i think it was la
uh san diego
yeah yeah la though specifically the
what is the thing the um it doesn't
matter the point is
they were the first people to do it but
sometimes the first people to do
something
are not the ones that get all the credit
notaries ericsson
christopher columbus yeah perfect so
it's like
tony hawk who's like the fucking
sweetest guy in the world
came out kind of after them and then
blew up
and i think most people attribute like
this
meteoric rise to popularity of
skateboarding to like tony and not only
the video games but also just his look i
love how in rogan you were like oh i
watched bill maher and i was like oh i
can do that better
yeah much better like i know what to do
yeah like got it yeah yeah
way better like not even close have you
ever spoke to him
no but i'd tell him yeah it is what it
is bro
it can't be great you know i mean but
it's like
it is what it is we're better and
there's four of us he's probably got a
team of 40 people there's four of us
yeah that's a way better version i love
that you say when you
um do press about
your show you say we it is weak that's
fucking
all of these all like the cool ideas we
can very few people
do that we yeah well they shouldn't most
people say i
i mean look i'm sure i've said i and i'm
sure i've taken credit at times but like
i try to say we when we speak about it
it's we we're all you know sacrificing
for it we're all doing it together
i mean but that's really it's really but
also like in my stuff like everybody has
a piece
like nobody just works for me mm-hmm
like everybody has a piece of it they
have like own some equity even if it's
little they have something so it's like
everybody has skin in the game yeah and
like uh i don't know i that's how i want
it to work but it's uh maybe that's uh
um
from playing sports maybe but also i
just think it's like the nice
i think it's like it's the right thing
to do it also makes the
show better that makes the show better
but also it's just like when people are
like
you hire women hire people of color not
because you have to it's just going to
make it better
obviously that's the only reason i do it
real real talk if you want the best
argument for that
a hundred percent like our writing staff
was like and just in general like it's
super diverse we never tried once
it just happens to be but what ends up
happening is
the jokes become nuanced because of it
and you see things you wouldn't have
seen mistakes you would have made
because there's someone there who knows
fresh eyes and then all of a sudden we
had this joke we were
in in the special about uh it was like
the body positivity movement or
something like that like about people
abusing the body positivity movement and
then uh
we said these uh these big-bodied
jihadis came out of nowhere and started
screaming allah snack bar right
and there's a cupcake right and there is
arabic writing that looks kind of like
the isis flag writing
on a black cupcake one of those hostess
cupcakes and the arabic writing
says uh have a great day but you think
it's the isis flag
right but then people who actually speak
arabic go oh shit i can read that
and that would only happen because we
had a kid who's muslim
on the show and he's like yo we should
make sure we don't use the isis flag but
why don't we put something in there
it's kind of cute so i'm not like this
like crusader for like
make sure your staff is diverse like if
you're a reasonable guy that like has
curiosity about people's opinions
you will gravitate to those people but
also at least in
our situation people just want to
surround themselves with people that
agree with them
and it makes them uh mediocre i get that
and i do i do get that
but like i don't at all no i get why
people do
i don't fuck with anybody that everybody
that i excites me
i get what i'm saying is i'm not
surprised that people do it but i do
think that like
i think the crux for all of us the
reason like why we kind of all
connected and why it's been successful
for us is like
all of us have kind of felt a bit like
outsiders
within our communities like kind of like
watching in
does that make sense yes so like we
could fit in
but we were always kind of like
observing it at the same time yeah
and i think a lot of comics are like
that so naturally we're all coming from
these different walks of life but we all
kind of relate to this like
way of kind of like observing the things
around us while they're happening i used
to
obsess over like i remember as a kid i
i would work on a typewriter in my
aunt's basement now i turned the volume
on my aunt's basement in um
virginia and i would like get obsessed
with what things are named
you know like jumbo shrimp
aren't shrimp small like i would get
like obsessed with like little things
that didn't make sense to me
yeah you know there's this girl in our
podcast taylor and
she said the other day she goes uh she's
like i don't know sometimes this stuff
doesn't make sense to me and i'm like
what do you mean
and she goes like why is it called a
building
shouldn't it be called a built
because it sounds like it's it sounds
like a stupid but at the same time you
start going like wait wait yeah
i would get hung up on yeah yeah i would
get hung
up on shit like that you know and like
uh
the like ideology of stuff i didn't like
you think people really take all the
credit themselves
i think a lot of people uh are into that
shit yeah
i don't know i just feel like i can't do
it without them so it'd be weird for me
to know
because you're not a malignant
narcissist but
i assume if there is somebody out there
taking all the credit they feel like
they can do it without them i just don't
think i can
so like for me i would feel like a fraud
if i did yeah
does that matter yeah but a lot of
people are fine being frauds
yeah but i also think that like whatever
it takes yeah i don't know i just feel
like
if the level of greatness that i want to
achieve like i could never do
like yeah i just could never
like whenever i say something like um
annie letterman did she fucking killed
me so hard
this bitch i was wearing like a um
like a nude bra and i was showing her my
thing yeah and i hold up and she goes
where did you get that bra the holocaust
museum
it was so fucking funny and it just was
like every time i say it i'm like annie
letterman said that like i have to give
cr like i just can't
i would not it gets i don't know there's
like an honor
there's a there's a you feel dirty you
feel gross i don't know i also
understand that like
i'm the face of it so i'm gonna get the
most credit yeah
yeah if i have the opportunity to like
it just feels bad
people know it's selfish i would imagine
if i was in their situation that
it'd be cool to hear yeah you're one of
the good ones though i don't know if
that makes me good there's people who
there's people in this business
who say they're directing specials and
then someone else directs them
and does not get credit on the screen
yeah yeah
there's people who say they wrote books
to me fair they did alex didn't direct
it he's just black and we needed a black
guy
look
at that i know you wanted the least
qualified person
to direct your special i've told this
story a million times but like
it's even on like rogan but like uh
we've just invested in competence and
when i say we like that's just the
people that we
gravitate to and the people that we like
continue to like keep on board
but like al has never directed anything
that is
that is on a streaming network right now
even better
yeah i know even better because you're
not going to be stuck in patterns and
bad habits
from other things and you're not he
didn't know how to use premiere
great even better this kid was in
college a year ago love it
love it he was in a fraternity benton
worked at sephora
a little different their
responsibilities but stuff no it's
perfect
you've worked in benton's dad was
handicapped and had to
take care of him all the time like ben
like yeah so that's what you you picked
somebody that was like okay if you could
take care of a handicapped person
you can take care of me that's brilliant
you understand hr and hiring that's what
you understand
i can i i know a winner when i see one
100 no i'll be on and i'm not saying
this to like to my own horn but like you
saw it in me before
anybody industry 100 i i am
bad at so many things but
knowing who's going to be crystalia like
knowing who's
going to make it is like beanie felt
that is my thing
yeah i i would say uh me too like i can
tell
people got it or they don't and i can
tell like exactly what they're missing
and i can be like yo you're great i know
benton thinks i should be a manager
but then yeah i know i don't want
anything from people that's the other
day
yeah that's i do it for free like i do
it i'll just let me just i'd rather just
help you for free there's this weird
thing where like people yeah you should
like sign all these podcasts and stuff
like that i was like i don't want to own
anybody yeah i
just don't want more emails i don't even
want to own my shit yeah yeah yeah i'm
just like
do you want to own something i just like
want to have a fucking blast let's have
fun we can all get rich we're really
good at this
i think we're the best at this because
we were doing it with nobody and we
managed to like kind of change the way
people put out content like we really
did do you think you're gonna ever sell
it
so what your podcast no maybe i don't
know if i do
sure if not right now i'm not thinking
about it this spot if i came to you yeah
i don't know i mean like that deal would
have to be like so far down the line
yeah yeah what it is like
really but yeah like i just think like
let's have fun let's create
cool thing i demand a lot for myself and
obviously from them but at the same time
like let's enjoy it like
they're here with me just because like
yo we should celebrate this let's go
let's go meet fucking rogan you know
what i mean let's go watch chappelle and
rogan do stand up
let's have some fun i this this is how i
think you should
who should i have on uh my podcast how
am i doing give me notes
you're great you don't need notes from
me you have an incredibly successful
podcast
are you having fun doing it i have to
have fun doing everything i don't have
any
i say no to people that i know would do
huge numbers but i'm just like i don't
have anything to say to you
i'd rather have you on again or fucking
we rarely
we rarely have guests because our thing
is just like it's kind of just a hang
yeah yeah we're not against guests but
we don't want to be dependent on guests
i was going to do your podcast when we
were in new york
but then you leave i know but i want you
to
like you i would have on because you're
part of the hang yeah but
having random people on like just to
interview them to me that would be like
a different project
we want to have people on there like
part of our
kind of you know circle family exactly
like we want people to get it this is
what i was going to say and i forgot to
say oh my god do you remember when she
who did she rip efe oh my god oh my god
i can't believe i didn't tell this story
oh dude whitney is the biggest bl
where's the camera she is the biggest
bully i've ever seen
in my entire fucking life dude she
walked into the studio in heeled
sneakers mind you
nobody's through out the window nobody's
had this much confidence in heel
sneakers
benton had to bring me new shoes comes
into this writing session
right the four of us have been writing
non-stop we're fucking killing it
everything's good comes into the writing
scissors and a horse jacket and a horse
jacket and heeled shoes
takes the white board wipes it down with
her hand like can we get some
organization over here somebody cast it
on to the tv his computer's
too little i wanna look and then we have
this one guy named effen
who is uh he has like a little like it
looks like um
soot on his forehead but it's not soot
it's just how his skin looks yeah yeah
and he's a muslim dude so people assume
it's from prayer
but it's not it's just what is it a
birthmark i don't know it's just soot
yeah yeah and uh whitney walks up to him
it's a skin thing whitney walks up to
him and he she goes uh
because hey yeah how'd you get here
threw a chimney
i couldn't fucking believe it i couldn't
and then just pounds away dude she was
relentless
it was like a real alpha fucking thing
it was like i'm gonna let you know i've
been in writer's rooms before this is
how the fuck it goes
pay attention everybody it was a real
alpha move
that was on some west virginia road
how did you get here through a chimney
who is this guy
i think there was a couple like santa
claus jokes yeah
yeah i think there was like a couple oh
yeah
it took him like a week to recover yeah
was he okay yeah he was praying and
shooting okay
i know he lost 20 pounds i think he
should sue me
he should when am i toxic am i gonna
that was
you were toxic in that moment i love
every second
i mean like am a why like a man could
never do that to a woman
no we couldn't but dude i have guys on
here and i fucking objectify them
the entire time yeah but that's fine
that's cool like like
it doesn't have to be equal it doesn't
have to be yeah we just get to be
superior now
i'm not yeah if you want if that's what
you think is superior
yeah yeah it's just like whatever you
can make fun of us you can make fun of
our physique
but comment me like do you know what i'm
saying it's also i call it
it's also my way of saying like your
hair i talked about your hair
fucking amazing it is what it is you
know what i meant
you know what you should be in an
aquarium you
you love it because it makes you less
attracted to me
so that you won't fall in love with me
and ruin your perfect
soul mate yeah that's it that's it
otherwise thank you dude
thanks for doing it for me otherwise
you'd be in love with me i'm doing this
for our friendship thank you i
appreciate your sacrifice male comics so
can i tell you something yeah it's
fucking when you dye your hair blue
people stop calling you for advice do
they i get
so many calls for like hey what should i
do about that like
you're changing everything you're like
renovating your whole home like
everything's a renovation like what's
happening called the great
reorganization
gotcha we call it a midlife guys
that's what we
[Laughter]
i'm going to kill myself next year trust
me
no i'm gonna dude i came in today i came
in today and there's fucking like
plastic all over this place like it's
just being rented the whole thing is
renovated
and then she starts giving me the tour
but like
no you don't give a tour of something
that's not done
right like she's walking me around
describing it it's called vision yeah
but like
we could do that from the living room
vision yeah but we could do it from the
living room
burn one calorie she goes she goes she
goes yeah this is going to be open
tuscany that means nothing to me
what the fuck does saying that's going
to mean this
this is going to be open think tuscany
what does that mean to me i've never
been
giving you the the top line no some
fucking landscaper said we're going to
make a tuscany and you're like i don't
know what that means but i'm repeating
that shit i'm repeating no that's
everything else how about this bitch how
about that's what i said to my
landscaper i was like i want to feel
tuscany
spanish rehab in the 70s i want this to
feel like west virginia and she had to
fucking
execute you hired a she
yes they did whoa i liked that yeah i
liked it yes i did
details attention to detail hyper
vigilant perfectionism
insecurity knows how to manage a lot of
things
mothers hire mothers they know how to
fucking do a lot of shit at once
handle people are you hungry you need
some water
women are very good bosses because they
know how to like read
faces i made a movie about it i made a
movie about it andrew's in it and i have
a call and i have a zoom
q a right now about the female brain at
5 p.m
15 minutes oh my god okay all right
people still want me to talk about this
movie
because it's a great movie i mean i feel
like all i did was compromise
but i got to compromise i got to like
yeah i mean i had it was we made it for
very little money you saw me
yeah i i had to do most of seven posts i
did it was a
you know i don't know i thought it i
don't know it's big people love it
people love it yeah that's all that
matters who cares we'll make a movie one
day
not yet but we should but it would be
like a um i already know what it is
okay it's it's ocean's eleven
11 or 12 or 13 but it's that vibe it's
just misfits coming together they're all
friends but are all unique and different
and then you're just
it's an excuse to be around this hangout
it's essentially a podcast and it's
improvised
it's pseudo improvised yeah but it's
like it's really just
bouncing our personalities off of each
other yeah that's the mo and like
it's like you know because i think we're
the new friends no it's not friends with
a rat pack
oh shit
literally theo he was great today
he's so funny man that's ridiculous he's
so funny that guy
he's sitting here he's just like on a
different planet
he hates fucking what i tell the story
and every time i tell it
he's like you fucking told the story all
the time dude i saw him
in an airport you know when you see a
comic at an airport at like 5 a.m
you're just like you're just like what's
up dude even if you like don't fuck with
each other you're like what's up
like we were like making a connection in
like
you know tulsa or some shit yeah it's
something like six a.m
and we're sitting we're the only people
in the fucking um
what is it i haven't been there for
until a gate yeah and there's the chairs
and he's behind me
isn't the gate the gate what gate what
gator is that what it is
and uh he's like behind me you know the
chairs are back to back
and i look over and i see theo vaughn
like i'm like yo dude he's like yo
and there's a tv in the corner playing
vh1
it's like vh1 like best week ever best
week ever i was on that i know
and uh theomond i just go hey what's up
and he looks up and he goes
vh1 talk about a network without a game
plan
didn't say hi or i was like nothing 6
a.m
network without a game plan like it was
just such a why
i was just like your brain is just a
different brain
today he said uh yeah you ever have one
of your friends uh
you know try to do a piggyback from the
front
[Laughter]
think about it instead of the piggyback
you're facing each other
and he goes yeah just lean your head on
my shoulder i'll take it from here
dude he the other day he said something
about he's like
he's like um there was that thing it was
like um
uh uh of a food with a bunch of salt on
it that made a little squiggly square a
pretzel
like it was something it was i'm not
even doing it good enough like but it
was something so it was like a braid
thing with some salt
and pretzel like it was just his mind is
wild yeah and it's authentic i think
that's something that like people don't
realize that like when they just see a
short little bit of it they're like oh
he's doing schtick
that's no that's how he 24 7. yeah
i remember um i love like working on
jokes with like in the
um lobby no the parking lot of the
comedy store
we're like fucking around with uh he
said he wore it
to a funeral he had to go to her
you wore a costume where you spencer's
gifts and it was like
it had a knife in the back yeah that was
like little spiders coming out of the
pocket and shit
no beetlejuice he wore the beetlejuice
like we were like like nothing is better
than
working on jokes with comics that was
yeah that's
the most fun about this whole you know
the show was just
busting balls and like figuring out
funny things to say
when are you leaving um well we're gonna
go away
so my uh fiance is from
a little bit north of here and uh so
we're gonna spend some time there and
then we're gonna go to hawaii together
nice yeah lanai have you ever been to
the island
yes you know that lanai was where
it's the pineapple yeah um who was the
guy
nope annapurna
oh ellison larry larry bought it bought
it from murdoch
yes and i have been there to that four
seasons lanai and good they have parrots
they have the whole thing
i went there right after we wrapped the
female brain with um joel silver
with joel silver i went um right after
uh we shot the female brain
and i was like in recovering from all
that shit yeah that's basically
what this trip is about we need a little
time to recover yeah phone's off
phones off you phones off you
what's the last big fight you had
honestly it's been a while
yeah a big one has been a while
over how shitty the proposal was
i thought it was good i thought it was
good
how do you think it was bad because
it was so much that's what she told me
in my sleep yeah like putting the ring
on your finger in your face no
no what if you woke up and had the ring
on your finger
and were like just saw it no the other
pitch was i feel like people do that
huh oh she called your shit hack she
called your shit
hack hack stop trying scented
she tried to put me against you i love
whitney
who did that anthony today really yeah
what about what about um that's because
he's
that's funny but is it also because he's
latino he doesn't take no for an answer
like you and what were you going to say
i was going to say also my other pitch
was what are you going to
i was going to do that but then it was
like we had already done that joke and i
just might
you know the spinning wheel on your
computer when it rebuffers stream yeah
if you watched our
special you would see that yeah no i
are special you are special are special
i the other pitch was in a photo booth
and you do a photo booth
and ask her in the first oh that's
cute you know first photo what an
asshole she is
she never said that to me this you're
making this up right now i thought i
pictured you no you didn't you pitched
to somebody else probably no
i probably didn't send because you have
a samsung or some shit
you got that green bubble bro i'm trying
to link up with tim dillon
two texts went to green put the phone
down you don't want this that bad
no that's ben ben is ben is samsung i
got him off it
okay tim is tim's uh there was no
service or something he thinks there's
no service
he's ten minutes i decorate his tree go
to his house
yeah yeah yeah uh do you want you
literally go there now
he's ten minutes away tomorrow okay um
i love you love you too thank you so
much for having us
don't you know this is the first time
that she's ever been on a podcast love
you too
i just i'm obsessed with you i knew you
guys are eating i feel like we're gonna
like have babies at the same time
i feel like we're going to be like
you're going to have i'm going to
breastfeed your children
yeah you're going to breastfeed my
surrogate children nope
you're going to like i'm going to take
some of your eggs i'm going to put some
of my eggs
like you're going to be my surrogate
like i feel like we're gonna have some
fucked up we're gonna
i'll see you in court she's a parasite
dude she's like slowly moving her way
i'll see you in court
whitney thank you so much for having me
i love you i love you too
but you have to have your call yeah i
know bye
is this too long what's what's too long
for you do whatever you want with it
don't write elephants
[Music]
[Applause]
you